attention attention bozos and homies we
got the card game for sale which is
running out and we also got some live
dates that just keep on trucking gang
the card game is running out we're
running out of supplies do yourself a
favor act now pick up the card we're
never making it again it's the last time
we're making this Edition so do yourself
a favor pick up a pack let's go uh yeah
guys we also uh this month in November
we have two shows in Atlanta one sold
out early tickets still left for the
early show and then we're going to
Charlotte North Carolina get those
tickies Philadelphia two shows are sold
out we got some tickets left in
Providence on the second show get those
tickets and Boston's about to sell out
if you're in if you're in Beantown let's
go let's party do it gang we love you
gang this episode is sponsored by our
good friends and established titles as
you know with established titles you
could buy as little as one square foot
of dedicated land over there in Scotland
and you can call yourself a lawyer or a
lady it's a fun way to preserve the
Scottish Woodlands yeah guys it's
fantastic a title pack gives you uh at
least one square foot but as the big man
sort of dedicated land on a private
estate in edelston Scotland an official
certificate with a Crest will be sent to
you check here I got it in my hand baby
uh it's fantastic I got one big man got
one T-Bone Colonius got one new guy Luke
out there not a landowner yet maybe one
day he'll get his act together become a
landowner I've been throwing out my on
my family's face charging you rent over
there uh established title is actually
running an early uh Black Friday sale it
makes a great last minute gift plus if
you use the code garbage you'll get an
additional 10 off go to establish
titles.com garbage to get your gifts now
and help support the channel baby
support the people who support the
channel it's true uh established
titles.com garbage to get your gifts now
do it do it welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
[Music]
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah well shall we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they're good to be
classy or if they're just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host Dave Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at antuti's basement she's
upstairs making a nice fresh batch of
kugel okay
in honor of our guests that we have
today my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he is the CEO of Ru
garbage he is an international
businessman he is not to be trifled with
in the Board Room or the bedroom give it
up for KJ how about that Kevin James
Ryan everybody come on hey what's up
guys thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate you subscribe
on iTunes full video available on
YouTube as you know those numbers are
closing in on 100K let's go let's get
there get that plaque yeah uh and then
obviously the greatest goddamn website
of all time
www.patreon.com
a lot of that money check it the [ __ ]
out yes we do have a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire had
his nose wide open at a couple of Casino
tables recently he's upside down with
DraftKings give it up for Debo McMuffin
Toby McMullen everybody what's up dude
don't bet on Aaron Rodgers or against
him that's all I have to say had a real
nice time down there in Vegas Kid Likes
the over what are you gonna do gang we
couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guests back with us again today we're
going to do something real fun with them
uh you know him you love him he has a
brand new special out on YouTube right
now that you gotta check out entitled
Jew his title not mine
I spilled a lot of crosses there ladies
and gentlemen Mr Eric shaffir come on
yeah thank you thank you for having me
back now you're all dressed up you came
in you wanted to look nice because
first time that you appeared on the show
you were deemed garbage you did not like
that rule I didn't like it you you
fought it for since we since that
happened not only that he will comment
himself in our new YouTube episodes that
Ari shaffir is not trash yeah I didn't
like it at all stuck with me it burned
me more than uh most of my uh defeats in
life okay so what we're gonna do today
is we're gonna go over some of your
answers from your first appearance okay
which you say you are not garbage I
think I'm classy okay all right I did
show up in the suit which is [ __ ]
awesome that thing's mean by the way a
little three piece it's a clip-on tie
though don't you lie that suit was more
than fifty dollars all right handmade in
Hong Kong by a guy who's a tailor from
Mao I don't know
only 20 bucks he looks like you should
be getting yelled at by James Corden
right now
the black shirt's brutal anyway
he's here he's all dressed up you claim
that you're not garbage you're going to
go over the answers of your of your
first appearance we're going to answer
you some new questions and we're going
to go over there we're going to give you
one more shot that's a Redemption only
you would we give a Redemption I
appreciate that you're the only guy that
asks by the way I appreciate the
opportunity of Squires
but before that you got a brand new
special out congratulations I remember
when you were filming it I know how much
work you put into it uh congrats thanks
buddy I'm really excited about I did the
roulette in Brooklyn home of the Jews
um oh and the landlords huh over the
landlords yeah you get evicted the
paperwork goes right through that
neighborhood
yeah yeah it's great I'm really excited
about it I saw it you showed me uh you
know just like a little bit of it on the
phone it looks [ __ ] yeah it looks
fantastic we've got thousands of candles
and put them up there to make it to make
it go with the uh with the sort of the
theme of the thing but it's just a
stand-up hour and you guys are gonna
love I'm really excited about it it's
[ __ ] hilarious best special you've
seen since
[Laughter]
all right so here we go you got the new
special out you're a new man let's see
if you are no longer garbage all right
so we're gonna go over some of your
answers from your first appearance as we
said okay Kippy you want to take it away
sure or do we want to allow him to you
you said you have a few things that you
feel are classy yeah I do have some
things
that you do that you think make you a
classy individual yeah well I think the
court will hear your case proceed when
you're ready I know how to uh do a place
setting oh what does that mean I know
where forks and spoons go and in what
order all right so you've been to an
Outback Steakhouse big deal he's only
sold a knife okay so how does it go Toby
up to how many forks and spoons yeah two
each
hey throw the Chopsticks in there all
right so you have the plate in the
center of the table what side does the
uh the knife go on the knife goes on the
right side that's very I mean I think he
struggled on that one
I had to do what it is first right side
I just so happen to have extensive
experience in the fine dining uh
industry does the butter knife face into
the plate or out to the plate out for
the plate faces in the sharp side faces
in because you wouldn't want to cut
yourself reaching for anything that's
very good I don't know
this has some Wikipedia written all over
it dude
although he has eaten he was just
walking around the dining room at Del
Frisco sorry we're not open yet although
you and we're not hiring you have I've
eaten at very nice restaurants around
the world I have international and I've
been to a lot of Shabbos meals over at
family's houses okay yeah
so this way I grew up along among class
and uh I don't know if a childish meal
would count as fine dining now I think
it's just a fork and a knife right yeah
but you want to impress the other
families coming over like look it up
okay I'll just throw like it's not a
Dick's Last Resort New reference
over there on Fremont Street Chuck
silverware at you what is the
um what Fork goes first the something
outside the cellar for Christmas guys
isn't easy to remember it if you're
classy if you want to protect like
you're classy easy way to remember is go
outside in what you eat I hate them soup
spoon on the outside dessert spoon on
the inside
salad fork on the outside meat Fork on
the inside
I don't like this new Ari uh uh just for
the record he forgot the cocktail fork
and the steak Knife is not on the table
until the second quarter steak Knife
do you get clear from the left or do you
clear from the right let's move on to
the next thing
okay let's not get caught up uh yeah
during the witness your honor I get
caught up in one one detail what makes
it classy all right so you're kind of
pretty good you kind of know how to eat
at a restaurant I'll give you that ah
listen I I don't I'm not typically on my
side but I gotta call balls and Strikes
here most people probably wouldn't know
that that we haven't sure you're on the
you're on the you're on the right hand
right hand for the Bell girl I'll give
you that thank you when you get your
salad fork you you want you ask them to
heat it up for you I no I would never do
that okay also you don't eat until the
woman is at the table as well
until the broad gets back from the
bathroom her nose however one exception
to that soup go ahead don't let it get
cold okay I'll give you that is that is
that an orange if your freestyle or is
it might be just my family I'm not
really sure just my Jewish Family which
you'll hear about an Ari shaffir Jew on
YouTube now all I want you to do is
watch it there you go okay so here's
from here's another thing that makes me
classy I've been to London England
you are well traveled yeah he probably
stayed in the hostel though it's not
fair yeah but but not Cambodia like you
have whatever you bought in that box hey
hey this is an American company
what's going on here what are you
ordering from those kids came here on
their own volition
um you had you are you are well traveled
you've been to London but it's not clear
it's backpacking and [ __ ] it's not
classy travel it's a bunch of Toothless
guys eating beans yeah I don't know yeah
I still give them I still give them the
uh enrichment of travel and even with
the enrichment yes he's a very
enlightened fellow yes you've been to
Asia I've been to Asia many countries in
Asia right you've been this summer you
went to uh France oh yeah France he went
there to take a writing class yeah I
went there to take a regular clothes I
picked up a hand rolled cigarette
smoking huh people like you smoke I'm
like Faking It
[Laughter]
you either look very trashy or very
classy I had trouble rolling I forgot
about this and I just couldn't double
what am I getting wrong and my friend
was getting it right and then we looked
at my pouch it was uh cigar tobacco huh
pipe pipe tobacco I want to go on a
record I'm sure it's a nice suit I'm
sure you don't look good in the suit you
don't look I disagree you look like
you're about to screw me on a Sonata all
right I don't like that he's turned us
against each other he's just get in the
car just try it you'll see it smell it
smell yourself on the inside yeah
where's that where is the soup from did
you get it made in China I made it got
made in Hong Kong China uh at a
recommendation from Tom Rhodes what did
that set you back well how much 300 I
was like 300 it's not like 40 bucks he
was like dude it's a classy suit yeah I
mean handmade too 300 bucks does it say
something on the inside it does rocky
hey come down get your suits monogrammed
Ari shaffir that's pretty good uh Hong
Kong Taylor Rocky what are we doing here
get out of here Rockies guys if you want
your own suit though plus oath
a52-236-80385 that's a lot of numbers
all right you're gonna have a pretty big
phone to make that go yep what's your
phone go up though
you can't be scrolling around on one of
those breaking arms so the place
settings in the silverware and then you
got London what else I've been to a
museum yeah
in fact I know who Frida Kahlo is
in Mexico's preeminent artist the bird
with the mustache that's right
I've been in a museum what else did I
have and I went to college okay you did
go to college you went to a pretty
classy you went to University of
Maryland that's right and delmarva's
finest and I said this as we were uh
digging your grave here you did go to
Seminary for a couple of years in Israel
which is pretty classy yeah I studied
become a rabbi there you go like dropped
out and became a pothead
I want the bacon round yeah pot is not
illegal in Judaism okay really yeah so
it's it's not even as bad as drinking
are there a bunch of young uh Orthodox
Jews smoking weed now there are really
yeah they've looked into a lot I've
talked to them Frontier Jews I call them
the ones you see show up at the they're
blaze in the trail they'll come to a
show or whatever you come into the shows
the boys come in have a good time seems
weird like what are you doing here
they're like this isn't wrong it's just
not right yeah yeah it's all right find
out about this and More in my specialist
for June it's online right now YouTube
anything else you're opening today it
was he knows a salad fork he's got uh
he's been to England you know how to tie
a tie I did it myself in the elevator oh
wait you got to wait also last time you
came here you had your shirt off and
security called me to come pick me up
Alfred did you not wear that here or did
you just tie the tie no I wore it I
drove her on a city bike the the city
you drove here on a city bike yeah a
suit made by Rocky in Hong Kong you must
have looked like a lunatic you know the
um electric city bikes yeah the middle
thing that's on there the battery popped
off and on 33rd I didn't even stop I was
late
I got to get to court yeah I just skated
the whole way the rest of the way
because they're gonna be hitting you up
for that you know that I hit the Do Not
Disturb what do you mean I hit the
problem with the bike oh yeah there was
like uh issue yeah you get more use out
of that suit yeah they might charge yeah
okay
travel to London went to college
dean's list two semesters been to a
museum at least been to a museum which
museum the Tate modern in London England
here I went to the met
I was the opening of an exhibit by an
opening is pretty good Icelandic uh uh
he wasn't invited he just showed up that
day I got free tickets with Adrian
Icelandic artist Ragnarok darlson that's
not right
I like his new stuff
what are you gonna say Toby I was gonna
ask if you got free tickets Yahoo yeah
oh also by the way it suggested donation
everybody should know that it's
suggested what do you anyway I have a
suggestion donation what are you
donating in said suggestions my presence
oh God I'm a public figure and they're
uh I'm happy to have them it's a higher
price ticket because of me I heard Ari
shaffir was at rig George
new grand opening
he threw up on a snorgensen
holy [ __ ] okay all right so now all
right and already stinks dude
sorry I can't hear about my monogrammed
he's got a monogram shirt too not his
initial by the way yeah
[Laughter]
okay so Kim name of the street he grew
up on name of the street he grew up on
this is bat dating back to your first
episode in 2020 probably it was probably
late 2020. it was July 27 2020 yes in
pandemic yeah
Studios just started open
um
we didn't even have our own oh you're a
gas digital or gas digital oh I think
I'm the reason you left gas digital no
yeah I was like what do you mean you
can't have a patreon I I just listened
to the episode that was a staunch up
that was a staunch point you had at the
moment
I think that's digital blames me
um nothing to blame we're all friends
here shut up
yeah it really is it's crazy
they [ __ ] around and created the
greatest Festival in the country it's
awesome it's really [ __ ] but that's
neither here nor there Mr shafir you
grew up on Pebble Street and that's
trash I looked back into it uh there was
a a apostrophe over the E it's public
so I was born because it was such an old
memory but I grew up on purpose Street
these Jews are shifting principal he's
quick I'll give you that the Carolina of
the north now a point in your favor you
did not have uh a garage fridge you had
two garage fridges garage yes uh we'll
get outside a garage which is Big yeah
and you have a freezer in the laundry
room you said still there however you
said the reason you had the fridges was
one for religious police because you
can't keep meat and dairy and also when
you guys hit a quick score at uh at
Sam's Club you didn't want to miss the
action so you'd bring it all back and
put it in there we'll bring it all back
the freezer is it's a full freezer and
it is always full I don't know if I told
you this but during the pandemic you
couldn't get flour
I don't think I knew that yeah it was
just one of those impossible finds
um and I was in my parents bedroom
basement and uh and I was like oh you
guys got like 50 things of foot did you
guys just get this and story like oh it
was on sale like a year ago we bought
so it has nothing to do with the
pandemic
so your parents are one of the causes of
the pandemic yeah sure you're a hoarding
they're hoarding my people the ones who
researched it and designed it Sarah's
selling Purell for 18 Grand oh my God
those are the Indians ever get caught on
one of those where it's like 14 bucks
like it says 2.99 in the bottle like
then go away oh yeah I like someone who
calls their own price yeah they know
supplies the thing is cracked and like
it's watered down if you want it or not
oh yeah yeah everybody was looking at
those times yeah
um we ask you what you got on your SATs
do you remember the score you told us
that day 12.50
is correct he's pretty good that's a
good score that is great again that was
the old SATs before they gave these
losers Jen Sears
however yeah we asked if you had any
pets growing up and you said you vaguely
remember a dog in the beginning of your
life that is not a classy story I can't
imagine the end of that dog's life was a
happy one it's probably in the freezer
I've done some more research that dog
was a hunting dog where we hunted a
whale pheasant quail and fox and good
deals if possible yeah that thing was a
blood I thought you should see him just
howling on Black Friday even just howl
non-stop he couldn't even sit still
where's the flat screen boy where's the
flat screen yeah he's got a good nose if
you know what I'm talking about you on
YouTube right now come back with four
Kirkland Insurance
you guys been to loves by the way not to
break in the truck stop yeah they're
[ __ ] competitor yeah yeah we get them
they're in the South and stuff like that
I think we just hit one of Missouri
worry if I remember correctly pretty
good they got some good merch yeah
they're always like you're like sitting
there peeing and they're like uh you
know shower 92s open
showering at the place you're getting
gas and nibs those truckers
what's nibs like the little licorice
swizzlers without the bumps I'm gonna
give you a point for that no no no no no
no you know how to get to his heart
start dropping name dropping candy oh I
love a nib a bad guy candy consumers uh
let's get those payday bite size what
are we doing what oh like the Big John's
yeah but they don't have the bite size
oh you want the bite size gotcha there's
bite-sized paydays Halloween only huh
yeah it's a real it's a real lack for
America they say this is the greatest
country in the world but not singing it
I'll bring it up in the next meeting
then we got I love this podcast so much
what'd you say I love this podcast thank
you buddy we asked you if you've ever
been to the gas station and used the
squeegee to clean anything other than
the windshield or Windows you said
yes you will clean the car with that
will clean okay that was in the past
okay and just like The Great Gatsby
lifted himself out of his bootstraps and
and made some of himself so do did I so
who did I and I will no longer do that
I'm a uh drive through you know one of
those sitting there and get the [ __ ]
enjoyment out of a [ __ ] washable
you'll stay in there oh yeah yeah okay
it's fun it's supposed to win a 300 suit
for God's sake that's how he watches the
suit I have not washed my car with a
squeegee in many many years when I was a
poor comedian okay but I have done it so
I'll own up to it there's nothing better
than a dumb guy trying to sound smart
yeah you said look then I will
out of his bootstraps yep here to four I
rest my kiss five six seven eight I pull
my side I pull myself up on my horse
straps you just keep talking and hope
that
I represented a guy in court once
however yeah when yeah I'd like to have
a go Rogan called me one day and I was
at home I lived like a few blocks from
the comedy story and goes hey Ari you're
my lawyer I'm like what he goes if
anybody calls you my love wait I'm
getting a phone call away he goes you're
my little hair and he hangs up and then
I picked up he goes are you the lawyer
for Joe Rogan I was like that's correct
what can I do for you this guy would
just talk about suing everybody suing
though I represented for about a year
he wanted us to sue everybody it was a
crazy person he was a full crazy person
eventually wanted to sue me or either 88
million dollars or all the riches in the
world
hey joke's on you he's squeegee in his
car yeah he would constantly use words
like here to four and henceforth and I
want to be like no no dude I'm the fake
lawyer you're the fake client the fake
client doesn't have to use these words
gang this episode is brought to you by
our very good very confidential friends
over there at Adam and Eve Hallie and
they stick something up your butt or
stick your pee pee in something let's
get the party started yeah it takes
batteries and it tells no Tales tell you
that right now you know what knows how
to keep a secret one of them the dildo I
just got from adamandeve.com baby what
are we talking about let's go have a
good time it's 2022 get a little bit
adventurous with what you're spending on
dinner and taking some broad to the
movies you could be in there treating
yourself like a goddamn amusement park
having a good time by yourself or with a
partner and I wonder you're like hey if
I order a dildo well they said in a
dildo shaped box so they won't do that
because they're not [ __ ] they know
to keep everything on a hush hush yeah
I'm trying to keep it a secret uh yeah
guys it's fantastic listen what are we
doing here it's 2023. go to
adamandeve.com select any one item and
use code garbage this is an exclusive
offer so support the people who support
the show use code garbage you get 50 off
and free shipping go to adamandeve.com
right now 50 off plus screen you can't
do it gang the show is sponsored by
better help listen life don't come at an
owner's manual nope it's a slippery
slope out there it's not all Moonlight
and canoes sometimes you're gonna have
choppy Waters choppy Waters and low
tides talking about Kate puts so do
yourself a favor get over to better help
and talk to a therapist that can help
you that can give you the tools to move
forward and have a happier healthier
life yeah guys whether if you're unsure
about a career change a new relationship
becoming a parent whatever it is some
broad ripped your heart out there they
have therapists trained to figure out
what's causing uh the challenge and
emotion and learn productive coping
skills with them which makes therapy the
closest thing to a guided tour of the
complex engine you call you baby better
help is connected with over three
million people with licensed therapists
it's convenient and accessible anywhere
100 online I've been saying it I've
always been a big uh proponent of talk
therapy I currently do it it's fantastic
you can send messages emails you can
FaceTime whatever you want to do it's
easy peasy as the world's largest
therapy service better help us match
three million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapist around
available 100 online plus it's
affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
garbage that's betterhelp help help.com
garbage do it however you use the
squeegee you do not get cash back when
making a purchase which is the
gentleman's move classy Behavior it's
trashy Behavior to go to a CVS cash back
what why don't you have cash that's
where you're getting cash from making a
purchase people do a lot of people do
get the cash back but unfortunately you
could have used that cash back when you
were vacationing in tropical Colonial
Williamsburg
admitted in previous statements is very
trashy it's trashy Colonial Williamsburg
is that still open I believe my parents
took me on vacation and told me to go
churn some butter I would [ __ ] take a
[ __ ] in the middle of the [ __ ] Park
sure it's not a thing I do now it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if you
killed someone in your your twenties
yeah okay fair fair still got dirt out
of those fingernails also big strike
against you Mr shaffir is no stranger to
the devil stick and I ain't talking
about doobies either the devil's lettuce
what are you talking about the devil
stick you said oh yeah thunder thunder
sticks yeah that's what the Jews had to
call them
swirl then get it up oh yeah dude oh
yeah right outside Grotto's Pizza at uh
Dewey Beach
hold on a second wait you just perjured
yourself uh I played the fifth on that
five second roll the fifth is five
second rule but you can say whatever you
want about murder and you get five
seconds I'm pretty sure that's the fifth
you got points in me shout out to Dewey
Beach and Shout Out The Grotto all right
gotta get it right out of the oven and I
gotta get it out quick delicious avoid
Taco Tuesday the taco toss is not to be
had or missed wait a Grotto Pizza no no
I I do it Beach it's Friday so they have
a taco toss at one of the places a Dewey
trash I'll do these it's just hard shell
throw them at you it's pretty much
throw them up afterwards I'm gonna talk
to you about a date and the time
guys let's all play Dewey Beach there is
Joan Jett was there once and if she was
there we could play there we did it uh
the same night the Bacon Brothers were
there we did it the same night I think
we were a better draw we did it before
before any success we did at the
starboard and it's like shout out to the
Stars yeah half of it's inside have it's
outside and on paper your girl like as a
performer going this is going to be real
[ __ ] tough ended up being fantastic
you did it it's a good time wow yeah we
did it wow that was a big payday back in
the day I think we each got like 150
bucks that's not bad and a free room
um let's see I gotta play the fifth
ahead of time I got a public urination
ticket at Dewey Beach with a man who is
now you can't plead the fifth in the
Midtown an admiral in the Navy and
Admiral in the name is a command of a
second uh uh vessel oh yeah that's
pretty good high level we got a we gotta
split the cop was like you guys can chop
it however you want it I'll give you one
it's up to you and Admiral in the Navy
yeah he wasn't then he was just in the
Navy okay and you took the ticket in the
name and then you split the peg yeah we
split it
no it's not nor is something you
admitted to on the podcast was cooking
multiple leftovers together at the same
time to comprise a meal wait that's the
question yeah I thought it was the
question have you ever microwaved uh
we're not we're not there yet we'll get
there this guy's hanging himself you got
a real tough road up I haven't warmed up
multiple
leftovers in the same like a like a stew
I don't remember the skillet not a stew
but you said you've combined yeah yeah
and we have the sonographer read that
back let's make something up
all I know is you're the first guy to
appeal something and then get a worse
sentence also I don't know if the camera
can see it or Foley he's got knees off
camera I knew it was off it looked like
construction signs look at his socks
Jesus Christ
oh my God
I knew BF cam when I put him on I
thought about it I was like he's also
wearing mime shoes yeah he has been to
France
you warm up stuff in separate parts of a
big Skillet and you have a monster what
do you do separate pans and you got to
wash two pants no you know that's not
classy stuff it's just bachelor life
this is poor Bachelor you don't combine
different leftovers in the same Skillet
to make some dark stuffing and chicken
if it's right is it from the same heal
no that's not what you said
same meal of course it was high at the
time because he was actively smoking
weed in the studio oh yeah that's right
I said I got permission
for Ralph it is stuffing season it is
oh yeah it's gonna be good okay however
because I have a chance
it's a Jewish stew I'm gonna make you
guys a challenge one day you especially
would like it okay you'll also enjoy it
it's a it's a crock pot it's a slow
cooked crock pot thing and it's just I
love that Eastern European Jewish stew
all right
really shout out shout out wifey Czech
Republic if you had someone on you right
now it might help your case but you
don't keep batteries in the refrigerator
which is pretty classy I have never kept
batteries in the refrigerator okay
that's classy or in the product they're
used sometimes you're so classy and
other times you're so trashy you keep
like something not classy well how would
that help
the battery it's not it's not people
crazy McDonald's it's shitty you know
it's true like let's save it for I don't
know why if it's gonna do one of those
leaks you never see a battery leak that
that salty [ __ ] that's gonna be in your
fridge we were told if that touches you
you died instantly yeah yeah you ever
lick a battery put a nine volt in your
tongue that's a good time yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh you have done you have to try it
yeah there you go okay yeah another
garbage move right there I've never done
it uh suckered in the next one we we
referenced just you brought up just
briefly trying to get out in front of uh
was you cooked eggs in the microwave you
actively cook eggs in a microwave not
only that you bought a poaching device a
toe that's a double that's a triple
that's a triple stamp a double stamp the
device the Target and the action and the
action of microwaving eggs in an apparat
your poaching eggs which should be the
classiest version a post check is the
classic if you did it right but you
didn't and you laughed at me when I told
you the procedure to cook the poached
egg what is it you pull it out with one
of those like one of those Nets at the
end but you heat up you heat up about
three inches of boil of water you let it
boil you turn it off you drop the egg in
there from a separate cylinder you spin
the water before you put it in there
until it collects together and you put a
dash of vinegar in there that's class
you don't do that you microwave plastic
yeah
from Target it's been a long time this
is something I did in my poor days okay
there was no I was at Target it's an
Impulse buy God damn it you guys got me
[ __ ] this is the question no it
wasn't at Target making impulse buys the
[ __ ] Kennedys okay yeah
[Applause]
Jesus Christ I hate them I hate them it
is a brown egg though that is an organic
there isn't a more fun guy he's
disgusting all right breaking the fourth
wall he walked in his suit and I [ __ ]
jumped up I'm like this guy's [ __ ]
came to play Jesus well I can cross here
every day
on camera good God
and in fact my mom recently said my
sister excuse me said uh uh corn in the
microwave is actually as good as on the
grill and I said I said no it's not and
I won't eat it corn on the grill or
nothing
according to the microwave was okay
oh I'm gonna throw off Jesus Christ you
ate that like a [ __ ] Komodo dragon he
ate it like a snake dude
like a bald Jewish snake oh God that
smells like a [ __ ] 1992 Honda Civic
brutal
oh God that stinks man
[Laughter]
all over my computer dude
we gotta move man
I'm throwing that computer away
God
oh it stinks thanks man
I'm gonna start doing that when I fart
I'm gonna whip out a hard-boiled egg it
made me laugh [ __ ] your pants the eggs
oh disgusting
there's one oh my God Mr shaffir
Ari also likes the chili cheese machine
at 7-Eleven
big fan of it oh yeah I did like it it's
been a while oh man it's been a while
damn that chili cheese was good I
haven't had so long now I'm starting to
think maybe I am
you are trash dude I don't
you're for sure shots all over my
screens it looks like someone egged me
it was a hard-boiled egg
you [ __ ] that's great sorry no it's
good you're good oh my god
oh so funny Ari yes sir you've heard
about peanut butter and jelly in the
same jar
I can answer that for you yes you have
yeah I have when it came out it was such
a gigantic leap in in the peanut butter
and jelly uh uh tradition and and
technology that you had to try and your
parents bought this for you which I'm a
little surprised at you didn't buy it
yourself he said he bought it no I
bought it he said he bought it you did
yeah I bought it even I remember it was
the rock and roll Ralphs on Sunset I saw
it I'm like what in the same jar no I
tried it and I realized this is not
right you can't choose your own ratios
sorry no it's okay I put I wet it and
then it uh I just gotta restart it you
can't you can't you choose your ratios
in theory yeah it's fantastic in theory
it's horrible if it was out of a two but
you could just squeeze it onto a onto a
sandwich great how about ketchup and
mustard for a hot dog on a tube it's not
bad together just go it's not bad even
amounts it's not bad makes sense maybe a
device on the back to choose ratio some
people like more mustard some people
like like a dial yeah two to ones and
then squeeze it out not to bring Elon
him on this yeah I know a guy who knows
him hmm
I know a guy who knows a guy who knows
him that's right
I played his fake lawyer once that's why
I'm actually representing them
um you got to go next never been
to a timeshare pitch very classy no
going for the freeze does that still
hold up it still holds up why would you
go you never stayed in a timeshare
yeah someone who owned one
okay and then I was like no
no just a bunch of family members who
like let's split a place okay that's
different that's different yeah yeah
that's I would argue that's wait a
minute yeah well you mean you and a
group of family members bought a place
no no uh uh yeah somebody it was like
let's go in then family broke into this
guy's house they went in like eight of
them and it's like let's all now we have
a draft on which weeks you get okay one
through eight eight through one every
year and then you move up in the draft
but it's all people you know it's as if
we all did my family that's pretty cool
my family did that in the 80s or 90s
with a house in the Poconos with like
all their friends there's like you know
eight families or something it's great
you leave some stuff there you can leave
your ski stuff there was in Tahoe the
rule was used in Tahoe yeah you set the
fire outside Tahoe you set the fire
there we go outside
you and 12 other people on the condo in
Reno
I went to French Polynesia last year for
Christmas that's pretty nice that's all
right
Mr shaffir yeah does keep his ketchup in
the fridge
which is classic that is that's the way
to do it yes however yeah he also keeps
his butter in the refrigerator we keep
it out just to melt garbage
and it's not to melt there's a butter
thing in there
she says butter it's not spreadable yeah
I'm on the fence I
what is that right out of the toaster
butter in a dish on the counter that
that is the classic salted butter that's
classic that's not classy that's that's
Americana from before they had fridges
no yeah that's when you had an ice box
yeah that was pretty good
what's the ice guy coming we don't have
room for this butter
I also believe that we decided that the
classy way to do it was some in the
fridge one on the counter yeah so you
have both if you're if you're just if
you need spreadable butter right away
you have it you're not keeping the whole
[ __ ] the theory is you cook with
unsalted butter and you and you dine
with salted butter which is preserved
now we're going to answer you some newer
questions okay to see how you hold up
we're trying to give you the benefit you
are down in the count there was one
question they didn't help you
there was one question from the first
episode we asked you if
we asked you that when you pick your
nose which everybody does what is the
where does the the booger usually get
discarded your number one answer was
survey says your mouth yeah you are a
booger eater the question I do remember
that I've told everybody like when they
were like what's this podcast when it
was new I was like they asked you
questions see if you're trash like have
you ever microwaved eggs that was the
one question that was like purely what
this podcast is all about
forgot this one yeah yes I have when was
it still due eat my boogers when was the
last one would you say the last booger
you ate was definitely the sun then this
week
it wasn't in the Deep past like a lot of
these questions this is who I am now a
lot of these questions do you come from
garbage and that's not what this podcast
is it's not were you garbage have you
big garbage all your garbage and this is
the first question that I go yeah yeah
in that Way garbage current garbage
even I don't eat my boogers I tell you
my dad I was picking my Rosemont and my
dad was like oh and my dad was like uh
hey on the plane he's like okay save
some of that for me because other people
are gonna other people are gonna wanna
um they'll get jealous and I as a kid I
was like four or five I was like oh
really okay they're really jealous yeah
that's what he said to get me to nothing
my nose and eat it and so I was a nice
kid and I went to somebody across the
aisle I was like you want some
I got plenty to go around never flew
United again
okay if you get a nice in Vegas where
it's all dry you get those nice bugs oh
listen I I'm a big I'm a big fan of
digging for airplane bugs too but you
don't eat them after a night of Coke
and then or you know
that's got that acid that's just a
little reboot that's like a battery so
you can enjoy your last cigarette before
you beat off again
um all right so let's get into some of
this stuff now all right
your Vibe is like Zuckerberg in front of
Congress
uh you know it's kind of hot under these
lights oh my God uh r d keep magazines
in your bathroom I do not okay let's
talk about established titles again baby
good Lord good lady let's do it yes
hello everybody stand and welcome Lord
Kippy and Lord Fatso gang for just as
little as one square foot of land you
could become a lord or lady it helps to
reforestation of the planet it's a good
good time do yourself a favor get over
there to establish titles and become a
lord of lady with a little piece of
Scottish land yeah all right best thing
about it we can become neighbors baby
move into the neighborhood the first 200
people purchases the title pack using
our link will effectively be next to our
plots within a few minutes of walking
baby we can meet up have a couple of
beers take over Scotland we can build a
moat around that land and take over
Europe
Kingdom baby let's do it uh guys it's a
fantastic
um last minute GIF and it's not a gag
gift it's cool it's fun it's actually
something you name a star after somebody
look like a bozo you go to establish
Chinese stuff but when you're gonna end
up there huh yeah even though uh
establishment is actually running an
early Black Friday sale plus if you use
the code garbage you get an additional
10 off go to established titles.com
garbage to get your gifts now and help
support the channel do it do it I'm a
type of spoke post BP box of awesome I
love these mothers yeah it should be
called the looking cool box because
that's what it is with that box awesome
gang it's the fall a lot of cool things
to do outside a lot of grilling going on
a lot of nice cocktails being made you
want to smell nice you want to look nice
do yourself a favor sign up at bespoke
post and get yourself a box awesome and
be cool yeah guys it's easy to get
started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers help them
picked all right what do you do are you
in the booze and you're into outdoor
stuff you need to travel whatever you're
into they got cool guy [ __ ] for you yeah
and ladies out there you want to you
really want to blow the [ __ ] nut sack
off your guy get him a box of awesome
there you go each box is valued at
around 70 but you only pay a fraction of
that price plus with box of awesome
you're supporting small business ninety
percent of everything that comes in your
box of awesome is from a small up and
coming brand it's free to sign up you
can skip a month or cancel at any time
here's the turkey baby gobble gobble get
20 off your first box when you sign up
at box of awesome.com enter the code
garbage at checkout that's box of
awesome.com code garbage for 20 off your
first box box of awesome.com
okay have you ever taken a bath at a
hotel
I have
nose into a cloth napkin at a restaurant
yes well you take them home sometimes
the the nose alone nice napkin
cloth napkins from a restaurant
Mr Shaffer I'll repeat the question let
me check that handkerchief I don't think
I have silverware yes it still take
silverware yeah and also I saw your
guys's live show it's getting for us and
you were like have I was in the back
just walking through a look at the room
uh where they filmed Jay's special and
it was like uh and you go have you ever
stolen anything from a
from a doctor's office well the doctor's
not there and I was in the back
what do you take from a doctor
the tongue depressors obviously even
though you don't need them for anything
for what is the great arts and crafts
I've never needed one yeah you put in
the ice cube tray you put that with some
some orange juice okay
and then Band-Aids shortages anything
you're in for get more of that this
guy's Bonkers yeah and a chair one time
I took a chair no
um I take the uh when I'm getting the
car wash you know they come out with the
Chamois at the end and dry them off
right before I leave I'll be like I'll
say yes again let me use that for a
second and I'll wipe something down real
quick and I'll put that in the back grab
it a nice shmata oh it's nice a brag and
you get a rag yeah hey you knew that of
course I mean I put two and two together
uh we thought it was also what they
referred to the uh the Jewish tailors in
uh in the Garment District there were
schmatas shimadas oh they're rag rag
makers ragman ragman couple of
haberdashers I like that
um will you open your eyes underwater
yeah recently I used to chlorine and
salt water or you gotta we can take the
scuba to oh I'm accredited to to what's
that 30 meters I've got my uh Deep dive
Patty
that's classy none of it was deep dive
well I'm guessing nobody was your
instructor for scuba no p-a-d-i it
stands for something okay what's uber
stand for
State country uh under under bridges uh
uh uh answer award
um yeah you got to take your thing off
Let It Go your math Let It Go and then
go get it right at 30 feet down 30
meters it's like 90 feet yeah and I'm
accredited to do that that's a high
level [ __ ] sport yeah I'm out of
snorkel I'm a scuba and yeah you got to
take it off on the song probably do it
so you can go treasure hunting yeah
thank you get me to do it they couldn't
get me to do it though like there's
quarters down there
I didn't even mean the Jewish joke I
just meant that's trashy
nothing better than wet boogers also
scuba diving Wishing Well we were
walking home we were walking home the
other night we're happy I'll just die
here I'm not leaving this booty
you're walking home the other night you
were walking home instead of some guy's
like yo what's up boring the one kid
through a quarter at them
he was like yeah what's up dude that's
real [ __ ] up and then like kind of
slowly bent down as he was sleeping I
was like dude that's crazy I know man so
good to see you guys
if you're if you're if you're at a
restaurant and you're eating and a
little piece of food falls on the table
will you pick it up and will you eat
that
no you won't I have okay so you do yeah
so I do yeah if I'm alone yes if I'm
with others less likely okay
um will you of course I will yeah it's
going to be a game time game time
decision both I will cloth of course I
won't because you're like I don't know
what was there yeah if it's an outdoory
thing no way I feel like that stuff is
good for your immune system
Maybe
yeah maybe to fight these things in the
future when they come these diseases
yeah the future diseases
um if you go uh say you know the three
of us going back to your place today
tonight you know
um sexy you stop let's get some beers
you invite us over come over you get a
six-pack yeah you put the six pack in
the fridge or do you take the beers out
what's the process
six pack what do you mean with that with
a with the turtle killers on the end
either that or like I was thinking like
a bottle of a six-pack but either way
oh put the whole thing in there you put
the whole thing in there damn it the
[ __ ] and he referred to it as turtle
turtle
aren't they trash 24 pack you put the
whole thing sometimes what I'll do is
let's just say this was like the 24 pack
you know imagine it's bigger you put the
whole thing in tilt up sure and slide it
out yeah yeah oh that's only the [ __ ]
you see on Tick Tock and stuff I I can't
do that well that's a frat move I pulled
a muscle doing that uh do you have any
baking soda in your fridge or
refrigerator freezer you do yep okay it
helps keep things fresh yes it does your
circle that is a classy move yeah that's
a classy move preemptive yeah I mean
you're taking you're you're running a
tight ship interesting I'll tell you one
further I go name brand Arm and Hammer
and or ham Captain yeah now definitely
the one that makes them yeah they're
really cool I've never seen all brand
baking soda how did that guy make a
fortune on just like stuff that soaks up
shitty smells he killed it
um let's say in your
this might be tricky yeah on Pebble
Street or Pebble what was the name of
the local pizza place and what was the
name of the local Chinese spot can you
tell us do you remember nah I left the
third third grade okay so yeah in
Maryland look it up what was it Maryland
it was the Jaffa gate and then uh which
is the pizza the nice pizza place okay
kosher I was only kosher kosher Nut
House it's still there Harry's Nut House
Harry is a local drunk uh at our Center
that's the pizza that's the there's Nut
House we didn't have a chance we didn't
talk about this yeah it sounds real for
us uh there's something the Chinese had
a Jewish name too it was um
what was it
that's fabulous that is fabulous no
that's an actual brand of uh soy sauce
oh my God that's fabulous
yeah that's a good piece of business
there's something Jewish related but
Jaffa get closed because Harry's could
beat the prices it's all salt were you
allowed on the gate Jaffa get closed
were you that house was the one that
survived I feel
Jerusalem gotcha named it after that we
allowed to eat in your room as a kid no
but I would you would yeah
party once homemade fresh Chex Mix
that's the best that's awesome so good
never had it since then the one in the
bag it doesn't do in any justice they
sprinkle the oil all over it or whatever
stole two bags kept it under my trundle
bed oh trundle beds are true why did you
have a trundle bed in case a guests came
over okay so friends came over I
remember the first time I saw one kid on
my block less than easier yeah slide
away the evidence
I should have blew my mind there was
always a man sleeping in there just
slide him out Hello Larry and when you
pissed your bed you could just just
destroy it jump down a level
were you a bed wetter I was heavy still
I'm so wet ah
16
16. Norman too yeah I know Norman I was
probably like
night seven later but it was a lot I had
a family friend religious Orthodox Joe
in there I was like and their their kid
was in bedwetter and it was like Hey Hey
I started to do an episode on bedwetting
me and Norman on skeptic Tech and uh and
they're like yeah I'm like maybe the kid
can get something out of it they're like
is it like clean and I'm like oh no no
this is kid can't yeah I don't I can't
do anything to think about it no way
do you eat cottage cheese no
I hate it to eat over the sink often
often yeah okay I [ __ ] am now so
deeply there's a thing when you're
skiing but when you're out of control
and you get towards the last like you
know 100 meters or so and you're just
like screw it I'll just straight line it
because I know I'm gonna bottom out at
this point that's how I feel like on
this [ __ ] podcast yeah it's gonna
talk so bad that I'm like [ __ ] yes I eat
over this thing I over the [ __ ] sink
dude yeah yeah and it does kind of it is
kind of uh
set up for that a little bit there's no
there's no kitchen but just like I'm
just saying it's leanable it's it's open
concepty it's I I get it it's trash I
would also say that you ski not
snowboard which is the classier one
classier but it doesn't smoke kids but
does make you a [ __ ] nerd yeah you
[ __ ] punk what are you a snowboarder
of course [ __ ] dirtbag
a piece of [ __ ] ruining the slopes do
you have uh name brand luggage I think
you're both nerds how about that
yeah I have uh American tourister
okay but I don't use it because I use my
Osprey backpack I'm not a [ __ ] wheel
guy we just saw you in the airport
actually let me ask you this do you have
one of those backpacks that have the
straw that comes out one of those things
separate attachment you buy the
Camelback for backpacking yeah
that's not trash it's not trash [ __ ]
corny as [ __ ]
from my phone
do you eat pizza crust do you eat pizza
crust okay good man
um yeah absolutely what are you gonna
leave it there I'll leave for a minute
what I'll do oh here's a move you can do
you leave it you act like you're not
eating the pizza crust make everyone
else follow their lead and then you eat
them all
they put their pizza crust down you
Sriracha all of them you're eating other
people's pizza crust
yeah okay that you said
oh is that what you just said for the
record
okay listen to this okay that's a big
strike again to listen to this kid on
Twitter hit me up and said that when him
and his wife will get a pizza his wife
doesn't finish the crust he'll save the
crust for like maybe the next day or
later on that night I coat it with a
little butter and put it in the oven and
heat it up that's a [ __ ] genius
movement no that's the trash you're
saving genius you're saving garbage
trash yeah genius trash that's someone
who owns a lake house sure
they're trash did you ever go to Deep
Creek Maryland no it's western western
Maryland and it's the trashiest rich
people I've ever met Lake people yeah
like new money people pontoon boats oh
dude I'm saving my money for a box
Fortuner yeah you're gonna be a tuner
guy oh for sure fantastic you're driving
down the street with my wife and I
looked at him I was on the highway and
someone was pulling I'm like that's what
you can get go on it and someone can
walk along with you on the car it's a
party mode it's a good time it's main
thing that serves no other function but
drinking yeah it's a floating you're
like uh and how what's that top speed
like one and uh wasn't the coolest
situation seven of those it's got a
bathroom on it too uh-huh all right you
have hand towels in your bathroom I have
one one
classy dude one New York apartment one
yeah so you can't replace it I can
replace it I have one with the
replacement ready to go oh you see you
have two oh I have six but one hanging
one hanging oh okay so you have six hand
towels yeah you sure about that I have
at least four I made it before we all
knew I was making up the number six but
I know I have four I was giving you the
benefit of the doubt because I was lying
you called me on it I'll give you that I
don't know if he's gonna lie I don't
even think the four was said with
confidence either I definitely have two
I know there's another one up there do
you have any of the following items in
your kitchen right now do you have a
pizza cutter yes do you own a juicer
like a Breville a juicer yeah yes do you
have that not one that you put like the
whole orange in it yeah that's okay like
a Nutribullet NutriBullet yeah that's
perfect yeah do you own one of those
KitchenAid mixers
or any KitchenAid products
not my department
yeah I think maybe we do okay I'll give
you the benefit of that you will need to
send photographic evidence instead of
fair I'll at some point you have a week
okay I'll tell you what I'll send a
picture and and you can stick up Toby
you can stick up this was a lie on the
YouTube
youtube.com all your garbage
um when was the last time you had
Lobster
uh not too long ago I'm trying to think
sometime this year did you pay for it or
were you taken out to dinner who's gonna
pay for a lobster it's me that's all me
I do well I have a special I [ __ ] I
spent half my money on YouTube right now
I hear it's killing it though it's
killing it yeah I was loving it make it
[ __ ] leave a comment uh have you ever
been ghost hunting
no okay no but I have sat over a dead
body once uh Judaism we have to watch
the body no not sit cheva that's when
you visit the Dead uh dead relatives you
watch a body all night so it's not alone
until you bury it I like that so as kids
they're like go do this good deed and so
you sit there with a dead body I like
that I would have lost my religion then
yeah I hear you
um so blowjob's not allowed in Judaism
really converting no [ __ ] no bacon
can you give them
no I'm out damn unless I'm said to give
them than to get them you're wasting
seed
uh do you know anyone
that owns adult braces
we must right that owns adult prices
like buys and sells it has a plasma in
the pocket yeah do you know anybody that
has an open collection of adult braces I
I'm what you call a knots I feel like a
comedian did I can't somebody has to
right
okay
I I would say yes but
know someone
come on
hey I'm no trashy not by association I'm
trying to by association my friends more
with the company you keep yeah
uh if you're going to a big fancy meal
yeah at night will you not eat all day
in preparation
uh no but I did go get those tickets to
the Yankee game and it was like Hey you
have access to a suite and I did Fast
the whole day really was it the Legends
or was it you were in a box no it was a
DraftKings box and it wasn't nearly as
good but it is sweet spicy sausage hot
dogs chicken tenders chicken sandwich
fries peanuts and man call me one of
each I was with CK and he was like he
was going down he didn't know I fasted
all day but he goes you're about to seem
you're about to be disgusted with how
much I pick out and I'm like I'm right
with you bro damn well also the real
garbage thing I think because when you
fast all day your stomach shrinks so you
get full quicker so you should eat small
throughout the day it'll work out yeah
that's a poor man's [ __ ] science
right now poor poor fat man yeah when
you know you got a free meal coming you
want to like juice it yeah dude yeah
speaking of the baseball games yeah how
would you handle this situation if you
caught a foul ball or caught a home run
ball of no significance uh-huh would you
keep that ball or would you give it to
the closest little kid [ __ ] that kid
[ __ ] right in the ass I might give a
little psych
hey there little fellas you're out of
your mind a foul ball you're also out of
your mind uh of the toss it to me
yeah you would actually have one of
those at uh at Wrigley in the stadium
somebody tossed on the outfielder I
caught it the only time ever
poured a beer on someone's face in front
of me whatever so and uh some little
kids some little girl comes up and just
hands hand out just just expecting did
you give it to her yeah good but you
know what got a free beer from the dead
okay still complaining about it too yeah
it seems to be over it I mean you don't
just come out there give it to me let's
leave me to choose these goddamn little
kids I got no respect [ __ ] free ball
that's your dad he's richer than I am
let him buy you a ball do you know how
to dance the Electric Slide of the
Macarena
you gotta know the Macarena I don't know
for sure but but you you could you could
if you saw it once or twice you could I
could join in but not the Electric Slide
have you ever been a circus day so late
Cirque de Soleil yeah it's not circus
this Tolle whatever have you been there
no I've never been to the Circus de
Soleil
Moon fry gets up and uh she does the
trapeze and [ __ ] oh shut up
uh what was your first concert crush on
her the Eurythmics really wow Washington
DC yeah okay ever taken an old-timey
photo
like a western or anything like that
like have the Tommy Gun and it's like in
Black yeah at Colonial Williamsburg
who did you play who did who played Jew
he was the banker yeah
yeah I'm sure that was the maker
actually
I remember in Harry Potter they just
made the Jews the bankers and like they
got big
um
ears
and they just killed them all for no
reason because [ __ ] Harry couldn't
get alone
I've never seen the program
um have you ever been to a Renaissance
Fair yeah I love Renaissance Fair never
dressed up for it a lot of [ __ ] going
on in the renaissance fair from the
employees and the people dressing up
real a lot of [ __ ] yeah a couple of
bar Maids yeah I do that I also went to
Oktoberfest with the with those juicy
shout out to those that's pretty classy
Oktoberfest I think it's classy it is
we're gonna do an episode of uh I got a
new podcast you'd be tripping I just did
it it's not out yet not out yet we did
one about Germany new place every
episode uh we saved Oktoberfest
specifically for another episode because
it's a full episode there you go do you
have a go-to karaoke song yeah what is
it my name is Luca it's I'm my voice is
not good it's all about spousal abuse
and I spin it to when the women uh hit
the men okay during the interludes I'm
like Matt guys it's not just about women
it's also men men are hurting men women
are hitting them and we can't fight back
please reach out to people who are
hitting men and tell them it's not okay
sounds like a real showstopper
I live upstairs for you
um before
hmm they're a crash a golf cart
no but I did wheelies whether I worked
at Woodmont Country Club and we had to
like pick up the uh in the morning to
pick up with a range ball finder sure
and we would just go out there and
[ __ ] hit the [ __ ] break and spin
it we do donuts and [ __ ] it was great
private club or public course very
private club Jewish Club oh only nanju
was uh
Herschel Walker no some chick married to
one of the abroad yeah but she was a
broadcaster but she was married to the
guy who one of the early like daytime
talk shows not more Connie Chung Connie
Chung who is he married to yeah yeah
stole golf clubs
like yeah they left it out once Connie
Chung did no me oh
stole a driver from one of the members
I was giving you points for it Jesus
Christ stop talking yeah
kill the Greenskeeper buried him on the
19th hey h Kevin let's get out of this
bank
and go back to our house on bibli Street
uh the credit score is good I assume
yeah very high what kind of Steel you're
running around with what kind of credit
cards I got a platinum a heavy one the
from Amex yeah okay a heavy one they
like you too oh it's great wow it's for
it's my crowning achievement points and
then you get something little known fact
they say you get free uh when you get a
rental car they say you get free um
insurance insurance that's a lie it is
like no we don't cover that wow what the
[ __ ] it says I know I always say no wave
it I got the AmEx kick rock look into it
a little more really huh yikes
yeah Emma so I got that and then I got a
a Venture Card
and I got a ATM card you've been making
money for a while so all that stuff's
cleaned up that's clean yeah yeah what
what like prepaid what would be a a a
classless move what would be a trashy if
you have a Discover Card Capital One
card which you do have a Venture Card
which is Capital One yeah but it's a
little bit of Adventures on the higher
end I have a proper just Capital One car
with a 200 credit limit two hundred
dollars don't raise it I gotta have it
what are you gonna buy for 200. I just
just sits in my there's something on it
for like if you get hemmed up you reach
it for that thing there's something yeah
there is there is something uh there's I
have some sort of automatic payment on
for like 14 a month you got a gun to the
back of your head or something like that
I need 80 bucks I'm not living a life
out here with suits custom-made suits in
the corner get you out of a jam
um I'm pretty much good here just got a
couple more things if you if you uh use
the luggage card at a hotel where you
leave it in your room the whole time
that you stay who the [ __ ] would use a
luggage card at a hotel what are you
going with an Entourage what are you
Jennifer Love Hewitt
well how many bags do you have you're
going in with a luggage cart we were
getting married we went to Cassidy's
wedding I kept the luggage cart in my
room the whole time what yeah trashy but
I agree you should why take it down
there's no incentive there yeah [ __ ]
them yeah I'm gonna go get in the room
will you do that with the uh with the
laundry cart if you have laundry in the
basement of your uh apartment we don't
have basement we take it to the fluff
and fold joint across the street wait
you take the car to your apartment no
but I've seen it I saw it left in my
elevator once that's crazy nuts who the
[ __ ] that lives and dies in The up in
the room yeah that doesn't get on the
elevator just to take it from one uh
washing machine to the dryer that's it
like yeah yeah and then the last thing I
would want to know uh do you scratch
your back with a fork I've never
scratched my back with a fork I did have
a Colonial Williamsburg back scratcher
all right that's it wrap this guy up
here damn it I mean he could have just
said no I've never scratched my back
with a fork and we would have ended up
what scratches the highest level of
scratching your back
Colonial Williamsburg no okay not if you
had to make it be a pitchfork yeah I
whittled it I will live while I put my
harmonica gang the special out right now
is entitled you you can find that on his
YouTube page ladies and gentlemen the
one the only Mr Ari shafir youtube.com
guys I just want you to watch it just go
out there I worked so [ __ ] hard on it
it's so [ __ ] funny just go out and
just watch it and do whatever you want
if you hate it you hate it but you're
not gonna should be called Ari shaffir
trash yeah cause let me tell you
something Double Jeopardy does not exist
in the court of garbage my friend you
are 100 percent
undoubtedly
in perpetuity and retroactively from
here to the end of the universe garbage
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
damn it
I brought a cigar to smoke for when I
was classy you really thought you were
gonna pull this off God damn you gotta
be kidding spit egg on my computer and
ruined it for five minutes Ah that's a
good point damn it
damn it and now they can't even say like
ah some of the questions were off
the only one that got a second shot
there'll be no parole there'll be no
re-trial there'll be no nothing sorry
we're burying you under the goddamn gym
yeah the first Redemption I even get
redeemed no damn it and you Jesus you're
welcome back anytime you want though my
friend and we love you all right brand
new special titled you make sure you
check it out it's absolutely fantastic
Kippy what do you got for him guys we're
all over the road uh we have a few
tickets left I think in Boston and Rhode
Island uh uh get tickets to those shows
we'll see you out there baby yeah come
see us gang we love you I'm gonna kill
myself
[Laughter]
you'll see something do they get a hot
special
we love you gang peace peace